what does the acronym MOM stand for and
how does it affect crime writing yes so
in in the crime writing the acronym mom
stands for means opportunity and motive
so
how does your criminal gain the means to
commit a crime so if they're killing
somebody with a knife where do they get
the knife from who how do they bring it
to wherever or if it's a gun or whatever
how or if they're drowning someone how
do they you know how to where are they
doing that what is I know it sounds
simple but you do have to orchestrate
that like what are the means to
committing this crime and then
opportunity is simply like a criminal
needs to have access to a victim so how
is that access given granted
how does it happen
um and so that needs to be thought
through
um so you know are they neighbors or
people who work together is it two
spouses again just what is and you know
there's like us people don't always have
access to us so how would they gain
access to us at a time when maybe they
shouldn't have or wouldn't necessarily
have access to us
um so like if we're in a locked vehicle
sitting in a parking lot
we should be pretty safe right but how
could well we think How could somebody
gain an opportunity to access us well
they could break the window they could
pop the tires they could you know Jimmy
the door but however so that's
opportunity there has to be an
opportunity
um for that access uh and then me motive
is the biggie I think and that's just
why what is the reason behind this crime
and I always when I'm teaching this I
always I'm like okay let's what's the
motive a wife a wife kills a lover
okay or a woman kills a lover
what's the reason why did she do it oh
she was jealous okay that's a starting
point that's the surface let's go beyond
that why is she jealous oh well um I
don't know he was cheating on her we'll
just go with a very cliche well why was
he cheating on her if she's so great why
was he cheating well she she cheated on
him oh well why did she cheat on him oh
well because and then we go we keep
going deeper deeper deeper we go all the
way back to Childhood if we have to
because
um sharp objects
all that stuff that happened goes stems
way back to things that happened to her
as a child and so that's the motive
that's the building of of the motive um
for the crime and the deeper and more
layered and intricate you get that will
help you really quickly inform the rest
of your story it will help you really
quickly
work through that second act which is
always a challenge because you'll you'll
know so much about
why a person committed a certain crime
um
and it's just a lot of crimes are Done
In the Heat of the Moment some are
premeditated but
um it's uh this this book I was telling
about I believe it's called the patient
with a we're following the killer you go
back into his history so much and find
out and her and the K and the victims
history and you find out why he actually
did this so that by the end you're like
wow I'm really sympathetic toward to him
I get why he did that
um and that's what you want right you
want that deeper understanding of of the
crime in the criminal and
and
how does setting affect mystery
you talked earlier about a small town
yeah
I love setting for me I almost think
that comes
first more so than character or even the
crime
um oh man this is such a cool place well
what if there was a murder here or I
think setting can be its own character I
mean knives out right that that setting
is its own character that whole place
um a Breaking Bad that desert setting
that small town is its own character
um in sharp objects that town is its own
character
um
the crawdads uh where are the projects
that setting of the marsh is its own
character and it lends itself to the
crime and how she was able to gain means
opportunity means and opportunity to
dispose of kill and dispose of her
victim
um so and even what the marsh taught her
about how to live in the marsh so that
she could uh get away with it so I think
it can be entirely its own
[Music]
um
aspect to the story
what kinds of characters best fit into a
mystery really again I'll just go back
to like it can be any type of character
the important thing is to give them
really great motive
really get really spend time in the
character development because I found at
first when I started doing this genre I
was very much a plotter and I was like
it was all about the plot and like
getting the all the trails of evidence
right and making it this like really
interesting weird twisty murder or just
making sure that the murder just made
sense right and that the trails of
evidence made sense and that the
protagonists could find them all and
like tie in like a big jigsaw puzzle you
know pinging the pieces together and
then I quickly realized through feedback
that that wasn't near enough that was
interesting to a point but it didn't
make it competitive it didn't make it
binge-worthy it didn't make it sellable
and that's where we want to be right we
want to be sellable and I
started to see that it while that was
all very important to know that to be
authentic in your forensics and be
authentic in your crime telling and
authentic in your your detectives and
what they do and your protagonist and
how crime is investigated what
what people are left with more than that
and even and obviously me too obviously
as a viewer and a reader you're left
with who were those people
who were those characters
and
that's when I had to kind of all right
to bump The Next Step Next Level writing
and really start
paying more attention to the emotional
journey and hero's journey arcs of my
characters and that's where motive and
really
developing deeper level of characters
especially if you're writing a series
right um whether it's a limited series
or
series you hope goes on and on you want
to stick with characters that are very
interesting and memorable
so
any character will do but it has to be I
mean any type of person or character
you have to find that thing that makes
them
uh memorable and unique and
only you can do that because we all come
from these very different backgrounds
and very different everybody has very
different experiences and we've all
lived in different Geographic places and
all of that can inform
who you create as a character it's not
something anybody can give you or teach
you or tell you you have to start
digging into
your own
experiences
to help you create those characters
and what is a red herring and how does
it factor into Mysteries a red herring
is simply a thing that doesn't pan out
so investigators like oh I've got this
you know this fingerprint I'm going to
chase after that and they go and they
chase after and they find oh no actually
it's just the next door neighbor and she
was home with the kids and she has an
alibi so that's that's an example of a
red herring it's just
piece of evidence that just you know
takes you in the wrong direction for a
second and then doesn't pan out
so it wouldn't be characters because I
was thinking about some of the
characters all of them like sort of like
their five and they all had their own
motives but you don't know you we
haven't narrowed down who it is yet no
it could actually be a character you
think this one character is it and they
turn out to be a red herring yeah so it
could be evidence could be a person yep
oh okay okay great uh what about rabbit
holes rabbit holes are
wow we've all been down rabbit holes and
at the end of The Rabbit Hole there's
just a hole there's something there oh
I'm sorry okay no but I mean in in crime
writing you want your investigators to
be like little rabbits going after what
they think is the right clue but at the
end they're just a whole it's nothing
and now they gotta climb out of the hole
and they gotta try another Trail
um you know so we you know just think
about how in real life sometimes we if
we're on the computer when we're surfing
we end up going down this crazy I was
just looking for shoes and somehow now
I'm going to Hawaii like how did that
happen right so yeah
and how much do you like to foreshadow
in a story and what does that mean yeah
that's a good question
I don't think about it at all in crime
writing that's funny
I think about it in drama writing
but that's fun funny question good
question I don't think about
foreshadowing at all in crime writing
what is foreshadowing I mean to me it's
you're sort of layering a hint of
something to come
and
I I'm just thinking about all like crime
other crime writing books or things that
I've I don't think we talk about it much
in this genre because you don't want to
do that necessarily like you don't want
to hint
you don't want to give us a hint about
something that's to come you want to
constantly trick us or take us down you
know make us think we're going this way
when actually it's over here so
I think it's a great literary device and
I definitely use it for that for more
literary dramatic writing definitely
want to put foreshadowing and symbols of
things but I don't do it at all I don't
think I use it at all and that I'm aware
of so